[Musique]
je profite de la présence de james bond
pour prendre une leçon de tiers mais
c'est pas facile
vous pouvez montrer comment dire il faut
presser la gâchette d'accord alors un
oui les yeux doux dingues qui peut le
faire en se tournant c'est bien l'amour
c'est bien ça le gan dossier et relève
son pistolet quand ils faits d'amour ça
n'est pas s'il connaît la bonne femme ou
non pourrait être une espionne russe at
il clamé sous son oreiller non lorsque
la femme est italienne est jalouse et
qu'elle veut mais un couteau ndaw même
chez ceux wanna go home ans et elle me
dit que je vais faire une scène d'amour
elle dit d'accord je sais que ton
travail mais surtout il faut pas que ça
fasse plaisir
james bond dans la vie je pense que
personne ne pourrait émerger le second
dans la vie réelle il est tellement
ennuyeux il est tellement parfait ses
cocktails sont explosifs il fume des
cigares qui viennent de cuba ils jouent
aux cartes comme un pro et en plus il
tue d'une seule balle avec moi que ces
mesures peuvent être prises
quel est votre prise de karaté aïkido
island
merci vous pouvez le faire à une femme
j'ai dû par les chiens
[Musique]